invité Christine du going Clément
bonjour Merci d'être sur FRANCE 24 vous
êtes chercheuse associé à la chair
risque du laboratoire de recherche
IAE de Paris Sorbonne Business School
quel est votre analyse sur ce retrait
est-ce que ça pourrait être un piège
tendu aux Ukrainiens et si oui de quelle
sorte
alors je pense qu'il faut il faut
remettre les choses dans l'ordre l'armée
ukrainienne a réussi à percer et à
mettre à mal les forces les forces
russes et ce retrait ne se fait pas
forcément de gaieté de coeur même si il
a été engagé depuis déjà quelques temps
ce qui a permis de faire un retrait déjà
des troupes qui étaient les plus
opérationnels ce qui est vrai c'est que
il y a eu des renforts de ligne de
défense russe qui ont été faits donc de
l'autre côté du fleuve qui lui-même
représente une protection géographique
et que les forces qui sont sur la
péninsule de Crimée et bien elles aussi
vont bénéficier d'un avantage de
solidification des défenses par ailleurs
en abandonnant cette zone ce qu'il va
falloir réussir à faire passer d'un
point de vue politique par le président
Poutine au niveau de sa population et
bien vous arrivez à avoir un ratio entre
troupes et territoires à défendre qui
est légèrement plus favorable néanmoins
néanmoins et bien les Ukrainiens en
avançant et à terme en vont pouvoir
continuer à faire des frappes en
profondeur notamment à aymars qui sont
maintenant devenus célèbres et vont
pouvoir aller danser dans ces lignes de
défense russe et donc pour revenir sur
cette question du piège puisque les
Ukrainiens restent extrêmement prudents
est-ce qu'ils doivent aller directement
vers airsson est-ce qu'il n'y a pas le
risque qu'il existe encore des unités
russes sur place
alors ils ont raison ils ont raison
d'être prudents dans la mesure où ils
pourront de toute façon faire l'objet de
frappe de frappe d'artillerie mais pas
que sur cette région là c'est à dire
qu'il peut y avoir un renforcement de
frappe sur d'autres zones du territoire
afin simplement de diviser la capacité
d'action et de réaction des forces
ukrainiennes et il est sûr que là aussi
essaiera de faire le maximum de dommages
aux forces ukrainiennes néanmoins
procéder à un retrait d'autant de force
d'une ville importante avec des hommes
dont le moral est loin d'être d'être bon
c'est quand même un risque assez énorme
donc maintenant que il y ait de la
contre-attaque et qu'il y ait de la
Défense russe bien sûr et les Ukrainiens
en ce sens raisons de faire preuve de
prudence
vous soulignez bien sûr donc ce succès
militaire incontestable pour les
Ukrainiens la contre-offensive a
commencé fin août comment vous vous
expliquez cette percée les armes
occidentales on fait la différence
il y a plusieurs choses évidemment la
capacité d'avoir du matériel qui a été
fourni par les Occidentaux les
occidentaux étaient nécessaires il est
évident que vous pouvez difficilement
mener mener le combat sans armement
néanmoins il y a eu aussi un travail
important sur la formation des hommes
sur les rotations des hommes et dans les
approches stratégiques avec notamment et
bien une énorme vivacité et une grande
capacité de mouvement de la part des
forces ukrainiennes et je pense qu'il ne
faut pas l'oublier en soutien
extrêmement fort de la société civile
qui a permis aussi et bien de participer
à des réparations rapides qui permettent
et bien de continuer à avoir une
logistique qui permette de déployer ces
opérations puis il fallait aller très
vite pour les Ukrainiens il fallait que
les Russes se retirent avant l'hiver
c'était un facteur qui a pesé
il y avait des deux côtés un enjeu un
enjeu de temporalité pour les Ukrainiens
d'essayer de gagner le maximum de
territoires comme vous le disiez avant
l'hiver
ukrainiens et dur et il a tendance à
ralentir les opérations au moins dans
une dans une partie quand vous avez la
partie de vous qui donc rend plus
difficile les déplacements et pour les
Russes l'enjeu était décennies de
freiner au maximum cette avancée
ukrainienne pour là aussi pouvoir
attendre la pause hivernale que l'hiver
et bien fragilise les hommes puisque
l'hiver est un tueur à lui seul et
d'essayer de bénéficier de ce temps
peut-être pour restructurer et reformer
des hommes issus de la mobilisation donc
il y avait un enjeu des deux côtés et on
voit que et bien les Ukrainiens ont pris
ont pris l'initiative et l'avantage
une dernière question les Russes
affirment alors procédé à l'évacuation
de 115 000 civils de la région de rerson
ils sont présentés comme des volontaires
qu'est-ce qu'on sait de leur sort
alors on en sait assez peu ce que l'on
sait par contre c'est que dans certaines
zones dont les Russes se sont retirés et
bien ils ont procédé si vous voulez à du
sabordage notamment des zones dans
lesquelles les civils pouvaient
pouvaient s'abriter typiquement en
s'élant les accès aux abris dans
lesquels les gens peuvent se replier en
cas de bombardement donc il est évident
que dans ces conditions là alors que
vous savez que vous êtes dans une zone
qui peut-être l'objet d'une bataille
particulièrement particulièrement
violente et bien vous avez tendance à
vouloir quitter et si on vous interdit
de partir d'un côté dans quelles
conditions il y avait-il menace ou pas
tout cela reste encore un petit peu un
petit peu obscur et là où les Russes
parlent d'évacuation bien les Ukrainiens
parlent eux beaucoup plus de déportation
merci beaucoup Christine Dugrand Clément
d'être intervenu sur France 24